Watching children in early adolescence
and in adolescence is,
is always eternally heartbreaking for
adults.
There was a great article in the Times
magazine about Christmas maybe 20 years
ago,
that the power of the Christmas mystery
is when you look at a child the same way
that you know in the story that the
Virgin Mary looked at her,
looked at her new son,
the Christ child,
and thought simultaneously this child
might save the world and he's going to
die.
Right?
So this like huge amount of hope we have
for our children and this terror that
they're going to die.
If my mother looked at me at 13 if she
read my diaries about how eagerly I want
it to be popular,
it would sound very like someone cording
likes on instagram.
You know,
I knew if my outfit didn't go over well
and I knew the way that a 13 year old
might not post a foe might pull down a
photograph if it on Instagram,
if it doesn't get enough likes not to
wear that again.
Right.
Or I decided not to wear that again
because being liked was the most
important thing in the world to me at
that age and for a reason.
You want to know how you're going to
play in the world.
You want to know how to be in the world,
how does show up in the world and you're
testing and learning what works for you.
And by the way,
it's heartbreaking.
It's heartbreaking when people don't
like you or invite you to a party.
And similarly,
it's heartbreaking,
you know?
Now when you don't get the response you
crave online or you get a response
that's out of proportion to what you
did.
But you know,
taking the risk of,
let's just take the simple,
you know,
instagram brings up fears of narcissism
because we're in heyday of self
portraiture,
which we've been in before.
There have been other times where
people,
you know,
sat for portraits or painted themselves
and you know,
van Gogh's self portrait is rarely
regarded as an it work of narcissism.
But let's say that we have this popular
form that as these self portraits,
staging them,
taking the photograph,
taking many photographs,
choosing the right photograph,
cropping it,
coloring it,
and then distributing it immediately to,
you know,
this giant gallery space.
And then like every artist trying to see
who buys it,
trying to see who's interested in it,
trying to see if it sells and trying to
see what kind of commentary they get on
it.
Um,
you know a lot of people who post self
portraits,
and this was true in the early days of
Youtube with musicians are actually
looking for,
in some cases for critical feedback.
You know,
remember the hot or not thing that where
you put photographs were posted and you
could decide I like,
I don't like,
um,
that you know,
which also plays on the right and left
swipe of,
of tinder is sometimes what recording.
Like does this work?
Does this work?
I'm in Beta right now.
You know it.
Do I talk loud enough?
Do I talk too loud?
Do you know that credible self
consciousness of like,
are my bangs a little too short?
Are My eyes big enough or,
you know,
how can I inhabit this body I'm in and
be an fit.
The exigencies of social life fit the
exigencies of a party or a workspace or
by the way opt out of it.
You know,
there are plenty of,
of of kids who are dialing back and we
see among millennials are return to flip
phones or to abstinence from computers,
um,
from,
from the Internet.
Um,
and I think that's very interesting.
The last thing I'll say,
you know,
when you talk about teaching my own
kids,
I feel very strongly that we can't adopt
a true love waits abstinence program
about screens.
The idea is not to teach your kids,
you know,
never go to parties,
never live in social space,
avoid other people.
We like learning to live in digital
space is not unlike learning to live in
social space.
And it's what kids want help doing.
You know,
I remember my mother teaching me this
incredibly subtle social lesson,
which is when you're describing a party
that you went to,
but another friend didn't get invited
to,
don't say the party was terrible.
Don't say they missed nothing.
Don't say it was awful.
It's disingenuous.
It's not.
It's not fair to the host and it's
condescending to the person you're
talking to.
Anything that you were left out of was
awful.
Right?
So I,
you know,
I metabolize that lesson.
I remember it was a sleep over and I was
eight years old.
Those are the kind of lessons you teach
your kids online.
Are you going to be the kind of person
that posts a topless shot on instagram?
Well,
that has certain requirements that's
going to have certain consequences.
Let's go through what those consequences
are.
If you,
if you,
are you going to be posted in all caps?
Say,
are you gonna use twitter a lot or you
can use pinterest a lot.
If you use pinterest,
what are you going to use it for?
What is the buy button about?
Well,
how much are you using this as to tee up
purchases and what are you going to do
with that debt?
How are you going to afford those
things?
What are you going to do with the part
of the Internet that shows your credit
card debt?
Say these are experiences that coach
ought to be embraced with confidence,
uh,
to be embraced with confidence,
not as though the party,
the people,
the city streets,
the whatever are simply terrifying.
And the only thing to do is lock your
door against them.
But to show up with,
you know,
uh,
the women I know got advice from their
mother that's too much black eyeliner,
you know,
that's too much hair dye,
getting,
uh,
I remember when I pierced my ear the
second time,
my mother said that's prelude to getting
a tattoo.
I didn't agree with her.
Right.
I decided to that I would do it anyway
and where a secondary thing in that ear
and that was okay.
But there are certain things that you
say to your kid like,
you know,
my son just chose his,
his uh,
his g-mail name.
Right.
And he decided to use his whole name,
like his first middle and last name
because it showed up,
you know,
no one else had it.
And that is a lot of letters to type in.
He's the got along name to type into
Gmail all this time and I asked him,
you may have lifetime of signing into
things with your Gmail address.
Do you really want to be typing all
those letters?
He said yes.
When he chose his avatar for Google,
he took a million pictures of himself.
He's 10 years old and he opted to have
one of those executive pictures leaning
way back for lots of like authority and
Alpha maleness.
And I asked him,
you're 10 years old,
don't you want to be like a little cuter
and more childlike?
And he said,
absolutely not.
I'm going with the executive picture.
And that was a good strategic decision
for him.
I think a good artistic decision for
him,
you know,
empowering our kids to think like
artists,
to think like writers to think like
novelists.
They are creating an Avatar online.
You don't want to be like,
you don't necessarily want to be some
Pollyanna Avatar who only posts great
things about her life.
Maybe you do or do you show up all the
time?
Vaguebooking and,
and writing sad sack posts and talking,
you know,
really vulnerably like a memoirist
maybe,
you know,
but those are choices that have
consequences.
And that's at that level of detail.
Cause by the way,
we all do it in our lives with facebook
anyway.
That level of detail you teach kids.